liebesbriefe als auftragsarbeit mit
fehlern oder vielschreibern zu papier
gebracht in der schweiz statt in berlin
wird eine vom aussterben bedrohte
kulturtechnik gepflegt die schönschrift
ja sehr das ist der persönliche ausdruck
das ist wie die stimme das ist das ganz
persönliches und was ganz individuelle
ich denke es macht einfach freude es hat
sehr viel mehr persönlicheres die ganze
computerwelt mehr als 60 schönschreiber
arbeiten für das vor anderthalb jahren
gegründete unternehmen die meisten von
ihnen sind frauen
viele haben keine ausbildung gemacht
sondern bringen einfach nur talent mit
bis zu 2000 geschäftsbriefe einladungen
oder tischkarten verlassen jeden tag
ihre schreibtische
wo braucht man heutzutage noch die
handschriftlich selber war dein bestes
beispiel vorher zu man hat also paar
notizen mal geschrieben auch ein blatt
papier
man schreibt man eine urlaubskarte das
ist das ist eigentlich das höchste der
gefühle aber schreiben sie einfach mal
einen brief schön schreiben in dem sinne
gibt es ja heute nicht mehr
ob eine valentins karte ein gruß in der
altdeutschen schrift sütterlin
kunstvolle kalligrafien
oder an schriftliche geschäftsbriefe die
nachfrage nach dem service wächst ein
grund handgeschriebene briefe wirken
hochwertiger als gedruckte
wer schreibt denn schon heutzutage noch
jemandem persönlich das sind enge
freunde im regelfall oder jemanden der
sich wirklich zeit für einen nimmt und
sie erkennen anhalt dadurch derjenige
hat sich für mich interessiert
interessiert sich für mich und nimmt
sich zeit für mich und dann öffentlich
dass auch dann lese ich auf den brief
diese handschrift ist eine ganz
besondere es ist die des deutschen
schriftstellers heinrich von kleist doch
die feder führt miriam sachs die
berlinerin hat sich auf das kopieren von
handschriften spezialisiert besonders
angetan haben es ihr berühmte
schriftsteller
doch auch verwandte und bekannte hat die
kalligraphen schon kopiert
ich hatte eine deutschlehrerin hat eine
wahnsinnig schöne schrift also
heutzutage weiß ich dass sie über
totaler goethe fan und hat ein bisschen
was von goethe und ich hab die so
verehrt diese lehrerin dann habe ich sie
immer habe ich immer heimlich diese
schrift gibt aber es ist schon ein
bisschen rein kriechen in jemand ihre
schriften setzt die schauspielerin und
theaterregisseuren auch für bühnenbilder
ein wie hier in einer inszenierung eines
kleist stücks anfragen kommen auch vom
film oder von museen aus ihrem talent
zur imitation hat die 44-jährige ein
geschäftsmodell entwickelt noch recht
neu im angebot die handschrift des
dichters johann wolfgang von goethe und
auch die kantige schreibe des autors
franz kafka beherrscht miriam sachs
inzwischen fast wie ihre eigene der tee
strich das geschrieben hat nochmal
exekutieren wesentlich gefälliger als
kafka der schwungvolle bogen von nicola
chemie
der franzose ist ein kleiner star in der
kalligraphie szene seit elf jahren
schreibt der einladungen für die events
großer modehäuser entwickelt dafür immer
wieder neue schriften und sogar eine
eigene schreibt linie der pariser mit
einem französischen modelabel
herausgebracht
wenn man die wahl hat zwischen einem
kugelschreiber und einem guten
füllfederhalter sollte man meiner
meinung nach immer einen guten schüler
bevorzugen denn so wird man gezwungen
sich mehr mühe zu geben und über die
worte nachzudenken die man schreibt ganz
einfach deswegen weil tinte ewig hält
auch die schreib stadt von thorsten
petzold ist inzwischen so erfolgreich
dass er sein angebot erweitert hat 2013
gründete er den online-shop schöne
briefe er richtet sich an privatkunden
für 17 euro bekommen sie einen komplett
handgeschriebenen brief karten gibt es
ab 8 euro
nur der wortlaut der muss wenn schon
nicht aus der eigenen feder dann
wenigstens aus dem eigenen herzen kommen